YURI GRINSHTEYN: Stackdriver
is a great platform
that lets developers and
operators measure and improve
service reliability.
However, collecting
a lot of data
will make it hard to find
the information you need.
And you may be paying too much.
Today we'll get into
understanding and managing
your logging and
monitoring costs.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Over the last two
episodes, we reviewed
using OpenCensus and
Prometheus to add
custom metric instrumentation
to your services.
But what is that going to
mean for your cloud spend?
Let's start by reviewing how
Stackdriver monitoring is
priced.
This is the current pricing.
But make sure to
check the pricing page
link below for
up-to-date information.
The first thing to
understand is that monitoring
is charged by the
volume of data required
to store monitoring metrics
that aren't generated
by GCP services.
This means that metrics from
the monitoring agent or custom
metrics sent by instrumentation
like OpenCensus or Prometheus
will result in charges.
The second thing to
understand is how
to translate metrics to volume.
The key to that is to use
a rough rule of thumb,
to treat a single time series
data point as 8 bytes of data.
So if we sample a single
time series every minute
for a month, that'll
generate about one third
of a megabyte of data.
You will then be charged based
on the total volume of data
collected for all of
the metrics that are
being collected in the project.
Now that we understand
how monitoring is priced,
we need to see how much
data we're actually
ingesting and storing.
And we can do that
in two places--
in the Billing Console
and in Stackdriver itself.
First, let's start with
the Billing Console.
You can access it
from the Cloud Console
by going to the Products menu,
selecting Billing, and then
going to Reports.
From there, you can search
through just the costs
associated with the
Stackdriver monitoring,
and narrow the report
to the projects you
are responsible for managing.
This is a great
way to understand
your historical usage and costs.
You can also see usage
information in the Stackdriver
Workspace by going to
the Workspace settings
and selecting Usage details.
Here, you can see
exactly how much
metric data is being ingested
from every project that
is being monitored
by the Workspace.
Finally, metrics that show
how much monitoring data is
being ingested are available
in Stackdriver itself.
You can use them to do
things like create dashboards
and alert on unexpected
spikes in monitoring data.
Now you know where
your monitoring costs
are coming from.
But what can you do to
actually manage that volume
or even reduce it?
The first thing to look
at may be your custom
metric instrumentation.
Frameworks like
OpenCensus and Prometheus
generate a lot of metrics when
you first start using them.
You may not need all
of that information.
For example, the
node exporter will
provide the same
information you were getting
from GKE node monitoring.
Review the work you've
done to add custom metrics
to your service, and
determine whether all of them
are really necessary.
The second thing you should
review is your use of labels.
The way that you use
labels for GCP components
might impact the
volume of time series
that are generated for your
metrics and monitoring.
For example, you can
use labels on your VMs
to appropriately report metrics
to cost centers on your GCP
bill and to signify whether
specific GCP environments are
production or development.
But adding these labels means
that additional time series
are generated in monitoring.
If you label your virtual
machines with cost center
and {} environment values, then
you can calculate the total
number of time series by
multiplying the cardinality
of both labels.
So if there are 11 cost center
values and five environment
values, that means that 55
time series are generated.
This is why the way
that you add labels
might add significant
metric volume
and therefore increase the cost.
Of course, labels
are helpful when
you're looking to
organize your resources,
but you may be able to reduce
your complexity and cost.
Finally, you can look at your
monitoring agent configuration.
Metrics sent from the monitoring
agent are chargeable metrics.
The monitoring agent streams
application and system metrics
from common third-party
applications
and additional GCP virtual
machine-level metrics.
If you don't need the detailed
system metrics or metrics
from the third-party apps
for certain virtual machines,
you can reduce the volume by
not sending these metrics.
You can also reduce
the metric volumes
by reducing the number of VMs
using the monitoring agent.
Now that we've covered how
to understand and manage
our monitoring costs,
let's move on to logging.
Let's review logging pricing.
The model here is
very straightforward.
You are charged
based on the amount
of volume data
ingested in the project
over the free threshold.
You should know that
unlike monitoring,
where some metrics do
not incur any charges,
all logs ingested incur charges.
Next, let's move on to
reviewing the logging charges.
As with monitoring,
this information's
available on the Billing
Console, the Cloud Console,
and in Stackdriver itself.
In the Billing Console, you
can filter the data to just
report on Stackdriver
logging to understand
the exact costs being
generated by each project.
To better understand why
a particular project might
be generating high
logging charges,
you can see detailed
information under Log Ingestion
in the Logging menu.
This view provides a
service-level breakdown
of exactly where the logging
charges in your project
are coming from.
To get even more
detailed information,
you can select the View
and Metrics explorer
for any row to get a
historical view of how
these resources were
generating log data over time.
You can then use this view to
create charts and dashboards
to easily access this
information in the future.
Now that you understand how to
capture, measure, and analyze
your logging costs, let's
dive into some options
for managing them.
Our primary mechanism to
control log congestion
is log exclusions.
They allow you to either
broadly or precisely specify
exactly which logs
will or will not
make it into Stackdriver
Logging and be
available in the Log Viewer.
However, you should remember
that logs aren't just discarded
when they're excluded.
You still have the option
of configuring log exports
to have them be sent to
cloud storage for archival,
BigQuery for analysis,
or Pub/Sub for delivery
to subscribers, even if
they're subject to exclusions.
Exclusions and
exports work together,
letting you choose
which logs you
want to keep for
real-time visibility
and which logs you want to
archive without incurring
logging costs.
The more complex
your applications,
the more monitoring and
logging you'll need.
Knowing how these are priced
and how they can be configured
can help you manage
the resulting costs.
Thank you for joining me today.
And come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]